hi everyone welcome Tessa Farias I'm
sorry I'm Jess and today we're playing
seventh gift which is very really really
old some very old game yeah 93 old in
fact when I was 2 years old so I've
never played this game and again we get
to revisit real-life actors acting I'm
acting okay so the creepy guy from the
start has invited people to his house to
his creepy mansion oh oh look so close
this paint yes will bless by his body
it's Oh a hand oh thank you man what
dear Olivia
it's like they just wanted to show off
all the cool things they can do
okay straight into okay seekers she
wants us streaming towards her haha
no no no you didn't oh my god
why would I be invited to a house but
all the doors are locked
good lord wow he like turned to face
this day yeah like oh yes [ __ ] door
band
halle-fucking-lujah oh goodness me oh
it's a puzzle Oh what's look what [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what did I
do
dad you what it what did i do what did i
do you have to cut it into six pieces
each one has two skulls two stones and
one oh you've done it yeah yeah I'm
amazing oh my god I did do it [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
I just flipped the [ __ ] out of this
puzzle no wait I skilled the [ __ ] out of
this didn't he come in with his wife yes
whoa the heads are waiting oh and go to
be less excited this game is alone with
my expectations immensely
oh my god Jessica look [ __ ]
horizontally he's George you [ __ ]
judge me okay there's one on each lane
on each line again okay then tell us
your spirit out so if you miss the
puzzle what we need to do in this case
is to place eight queens in the way so
that they're not directly within the
line of attack of each other as well as
covering every single square on the
board I love that this song is like 20
seconds long and this is the best dream
ever don't you guys worry this it's just
a matter of time huh
succeeding this oh my god ah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] idiot oh god oh god wait I got
this I got this
I I don't have it oh my good lord
holy Christ cakes this is the [ __ ]
worst dream ever
I'm 100 percent away
this is hilarious is terrible time I try
and think I'm close [ __ ] you I want you
there anyway
oh my god need you I don't need you then
see if I care
you're somewhere else you piece of crap
I give up you forever remember his chest
McDonald oh that was a bad square I just
clicked so I got rid of many of the
pieces someone press the straw poll
what is the snowfall hey you guys
someone presses the straw poll thank you
very much not very good eye for this
rifle wait fella said I remember the old
days when this wasn't happening let's
say what the straw poll is that yes it's
still no creepy I don't think that when
mirrors do different things than the
people that's creepy
what the bulls is going on Oh God
oh yeah she's going really young oh that
baby would be like outraged right now
holy crazy it's really really well the
answer is d Thanks maybe we can go back
let's go guys
ah Bulls in hell is this guy is oh god
that's why I didn't make [ __ ] sense
twice click on finish just guys ready
what nothing oh my go what happened
nothing that cannot be fixed
boot booty bloody is it bloody oh is
that an L must be yeah I think oh my god
it's holy [ __ ] this is awkward
this is awkward this is awkward burn
that for my memories do that hits like
nothing back of the bed all right Oh
puzzle me [ __ ]
Oh No
all I have is music is so much more
tense well just we can never get enough
chest
oh just everybody loves chess [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jessica what check check check it
out what am i doing oh my gosh we're
making progress
these guys out and I can't get them out
unless I move him across chicken know
the egg scenario yeah well I got them in
a patent it's just not the right pattern
I don't know
I earned how I do it I'm asking me
you're losing it it's finally happened
everyone saw you first
Chester McDonald this is the plot gives
arena guy okay I'm asking them what do
they want to see use the hints please
cheat is beating cheating is sucky for
suckas Duchy essentially what we've done
is placed three puzzle alright just
received okay ready
do you want to see two to equal B 1 to D
3
this is really complicated oh god that
was unpossible that was basically three
puzzles for two hours uh
you might as well yeah if you wanna play
this game with some GOG it's also one of
a bunch of other platforms including iOS
and whatnot um have a good weekend
everyone thanks guys